this episode brought to you by the
Dollar Shave Club a great shave at a
great price conveniently delivered right
to your home will you just let me watch
it oh for God's sake Hey
nothing just trying to watch country
bass are you sure you mean country bears
yes the Disney ride yes why oh he's
gonna go on a 911 there's no way that
this can't be an emergency
[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia good guy
remember it so you don't have to today's
movie has a bit of a reputation kind of
like Disney has had over certain periods
of time through the constant ups and
downs Disney has always found some niche
to creatively exploit in that you need
little creativity to exploit it
you name it directed DVDs sequels Kid
Rock stars
it turns out even then they were trying
too hard as all they had to do was reap
release their animated movies with the
lines erased we'll let this creatively
bankrupt point in their lives they were
really big into turning their rides into
movies they had a big hit with Pirates
of the Caribbean a big miss with the
Haunted Mansion but all of this began
with the most bizarre of rides to start
this most bizarre of trends the Cutty
there
[Music]
an idea so rich they forgot to even put
jamberry in the title this is a movie
I've referenced a lot in the past but
I'll admit have never seen all the way
through I just fast forwarded to the
Christopher Walken scenes and so did you
the film was less than a hit at the box
office got pretty torn apart by critics
and was often the punchline of jokes
about unsuccessful Disney films knock
knock who's there
country bears country bears who exactly
he drew my attention more though when I
saw Animaniacs writer and producer Peter
Hastings directed it this dude has had
some big titles under his belt so I
figure something of value has to come
out of it and yes I'm aware I just said
something of value has to come out of
the country bears movie how much you may
ask well let's willingly find out let's
put on two 2002 cinematic question mark
country bears the film opens trying to
convince us that the Bears were legit
country band and I'm not gonna lie
they try so hard to make you look legit
it's kind of hilarious
[Applause]
[Music]
I just waiting for VH was by the music
intro to play around it the bear sold
out countless shows to millions of
confused looking fans sometimes they'd
even stare blankly at the stage like
lifeless mannequins but then everything
changed when the teddy grahams bears
began touring those guns the country
fairs officially broke out that for the
ninety one hibernation tour taking into
account there were no bears in that
audience many blamed human grizzly
segregation Willie Nelson a former
country bear himself drew much influence
and that's why I was so sad to see now
I'm just figuring out now that they were
real and not a result of the wacky
tabacky see that's the real tragedy this
little guy watching TV is Barry voiced
by hailey Joe Osmond who nowadays could
play this role without the suit he can't
help but feel like he doesn't belong
with his family mom am i adopted ok
Alamut i bealive i said this kind of
joke didn't always get a laugh out of me
but it could have used Steve Martin
saying you mean I'm gonna stay this
color Chris yeah I hear I thought I
heard you laughing well yeah I saw a
funny scene ok well you are aware that
you're watching country bears right for
God's sake I'm giving this movie a fair
shot even if it is country bears okay I
know you're totally fine than their
critic you're totally that's a lie and I
need you to get here as soon as possible
Berry has to deal with his early
two-thousands brother Dex who I swear
all bought from a restore who constantly
mots Barry
and can you blame him the parents are
kind of needlessly cruel to him even if
you were adopted we would love you as
much as we love Dexter maybe more he's
right he does get a pretty funny
comeback scene that wow really
and did you know that nobody cares that
face is hilarious
as if his father is thinking like God he
stopped me with a spoon I can no longer
control him it's legit funny I find
things escalate pretty fast when Dex
comes in and reveals that he's adopted
and Barry decides to run away like just
within a few minutes don't worry though
unless you know pacing is as important
in this film as giving that psychotic
face of death off Barry's mug you may
think I reference the lack of emotion in
this film as a bad thing but did the
film's credit it knows not to waste time
on stuff like this it's aware that a lot
of people watching or simply tuning in
to see how goddamn crazy it gets and
brother they deliver on that fast
enter Christopher Walken has resembled
an evil businessman who wants to tear
down their Hall and I swear to God I had
never seen Christopher Walken act so
serious he actually seems more
comfortable acting with animatronic
bears than he does real people six years
$20,000 must be tough do you like to
sound of crunching wood I do
I'm sorry she brings his a-game to this
he knows exactly what to give how to
give it and how to make it funny 25
cents you have change for a hundred
I thought you weren't coming back until
you could tear the place down that's a
whole four days away Henry Oh like
that's gonna help honestly I wouldn't be
surprised if the whole movie came out of
his head all right mr. Walken we're all
set to film the origin story of Hannah
Montana mama bears what bears do you
mean like Hanako
to the zoo half the cast should be bears
well I don't think that matches Hannah
Montana buddy I'm not budging on the
bear thing well your contract says the
contract says I own busines now what my
god it does how did that happen I've
ways and you'll notice you won't get
control back until the BAM movie is made
with me I like hats meanwhile Berry's
family calls the police to see if they
can find him what do I even say
sometimes it's so odd and random you
feel like you have no choice but to
laugh but being cornered by Steven
Seagal and clown makeup you laugh out
loud because you feel like there's no
other option cutie pie meanwhile Barry
C's bear Hall is about to be closed down
I mean destroyed and big cartoony
letters as he looks over with the owner
of the place how great it used to be
jimmy hendrix open here for Vanilla
Fudge but nobody but nobody was like the
country bears keep them sitting
everywhere even up in the rafters now
it's all Splash Mountain dubstep and
teacup rappers I belong here together
that's just insane you know half of them
joined the rock of fire explosions
that's the stupidest thing but their
horn lay corn can't help but remember
the good old days
[Applause]
and we hosted everybody here the chip
moans power line coming out of their
shells tour and so many Christian bands
if we're gonna get the band back
together we're gonna need some
transportation
he then agrees to get the band back
together we're on a mission from fives
as they pull their old touring bus out
of storage I've been sleeping in there
for years who's President Donald Trump
oh really who's president the movie
senses parents want to get home so fast
for its to get the Bears to their
destination faster excuse me
sorry I got a big part of the video
shoot I kind of am you Wow they got
Crystal Harris singer you're fred
bedderhead Fred from the country bears
yeah
actually I'm Nicolas Cage in a bear suit
looking for women to punch I'm in a
12-step program to get over it speaking
of banding together to get through
something this musical moment starts
[Music]
fun fact they had to do 50 retakes
because all the people with instruments
kept kissing their pants with laughter
trying to keep a straight face around
girls and Claire covered in hairy mold
it seemed the final product you wouldn't
think that you would know that you know
people never tell you this is what
Shelley Duvall continued to see in the
bear scene from the shining
they asked Fred to be in the band but
Fred wonders how they're gonna get
people to the show why don't you go rip
Holland rip Hobbit the dad stole the
band from me call rip yeah rip all rip
I want to do one of those funny things
like you ever watch F Troop in a car
it's like there's no way I'm wearing the
dress and for suckers like you're
wearing that dress and nigga it's like
no way nohow there's no way I'm wearing
that dress and then they went blue any
cons wearing a dress
yes ripped if he can set up a show at
Bear Hall and ripps response is the same
Jason Momoa swipe tells them every night
well it's gonna be a squeeze but I can
fit it in and as lame as that lead into
him picking up the phone is it is
followed by a very funny joke I am so
back baby use me sir this is the last
time I'm gonna tell you you're gonna
have to leave the store yeah right like
I need you you know this movie can
actually get a few genuine laughs out of
me
what critic did we hear you laughing at
country bears oh yes I laughed at
country bears you see he's met critic
you're not well you need medical
attention immediately I'll piss off come
on critic you have some sort of shocky
thing for you what does it do I don't
know screw you guys I'm gonna like
whatever I like in this and none of you
can stop me Oh
yeah well he's got his let's get here
hold on a second I can't let you leave
when there's a man watching country
bears in there this calls for drastic
action oh yeah no I didn't have anything
I was just walking away to think Oh
so the bear is tried to get everyone
together to do the show by Saturday boy
somebody hire Billy McFarland to plan
this as Barry looks over their past
competitions and notices one of the acts
that lost he was a bad loser for
settlers to Jabberjaw on The Neptunes
now this go back to bear country
meanwhile walking comes back to be the
most committed he's ever been since deer
hunter rip Holland to promote it rip
Holland come here you see look at that
reaction you know it's like it finally
hit him my god Bess we don't let them
catch on and you may get it out nights
don't for the life of me don't know what
he said there you can replace it with a
duck quacking you make as much sense the
Bears go to the swarming hive honey club
where you guessed it they only serve
honey and it's weirdly populated by both
bears and people I just assumed this is
euthanasia for diabetics excuse me bitch
when you're good to mama bear mama bears
good to you they go to pick up a member
of the band names it but it turns out he
owes money to queen bee Latifah here I
do hope this can be solved with annoying
music zeb zoober owes me a whole heap of
money well as little friend there has
proposed a wager my house band versus
Zeb's fiddle and little musical doom I
think the bars accountant is shitting
himself I continued he went he nothing
but if he loses I get to keep the
country bear two of us as a reward or
punishment so I guess it's a country rap
battle of sorts as the two musicians
dish out insults
[Music]
might I recommend not pissing off the
bear I mean he is still a bear I feel
like any second this is gonna end with
butts if ends up winning though I'm not
entirely sure who judged and we cut the
Christopher Walken in his office fun
fact this is what he does ten minutes
before every shoot mr. Walken you were
supposed to just say a line into the
phone what's with the missing pants
bunny slippers and is that an anvil did
you bring an anvil to this big crush are
you doing that again are you really
doing that yes you know what just roll
I'm sure we can use it for something
[Applause]
doing great Chris doing great stories
for true balsa fury was supposed to be a
drama this big crush the Bears go to
pick up another member named Tennessee
who's become an emotionally imbalanced
marriage counselor ed yes that is as
hauntingly surreal as it sounds I mean
what do you think what do I think
thank you too so dying lucky to have
each other how can nobody laugh at this
it is just so unjustifiably insane
it gets even stranger when he has a
mental breakdown over his lost love who
he still keeps pictures of this is just
so uncomfortably cuckoo
such madness you can call it exactly
that madness what are you guys doing in
here it took us a long time to lockpick
through the door it was unlocked
regardless we are gonna take you away
from English away from despair away from
cuddly bears Chucky thing ready Chuck
Chuck Chuck okay look I enjoyed the film
ironically the same way I would enjoy is
the room or Birdemic then you
acknowledge there is nothing
legitimately funny in this not one laugh
was for the intended purpose
not one giggle was because of good
timing not one bit of enjoyment
indicated that the filmmakers knew what
they were doing
look I'm getting away
Oh critic you know that this is wrong I
know I can figure this out predict
there's only one way to figure this out
patience love and shocky things doesn't
leave me alone I gotta go through this
myself
[Music]
the first thing you think of when you
hear Dollar Shave Club is probably this
[Music]
but that's not what it is at all what's
wrong with the our shave club is a great
service that delivers great razors to
your house we all have our everyday
grooming routine from showering to
brushing our teeth and yes shaving for
example I always shave my head
as well as other things because that's
not what Dollar Shave Club is doesn't
mean I still can't enjoy it no matter
your routine Dollar Shave Club has
everything you need to help you look
feel and smell your best a lot of people
who heard of Dollar Shave Club probably
think they just do razors but that's not
true Dallas shave club can solve all
your grooming needs in one box shower
products oral care products hair
products skin products but wipes I will
never get tired of saying that in a
sponsor and obviously shaving products
basically if you have a body they have
you covered not only do they ship them
right to your house but the more you buy
the more you save
they call it their handsome discount and
now is the time to see how amazing and
high-quality their products are because
right now they have a great offer where
you can get their shave shower or oral
starter kit each just for five bucks
they sent me all three of their starter
sets check it out the shave starter set
comes with the executive razor and three
ounce tube of dr. Carver's shave butter
the oral care starter set comes with
their weighty toothbrush and a trial
sized version of their toothpaste and
the shower starter set comes with three
trial sized versions of their amber
lavender body cleanser citrus and
Hawaiian ginger face cleanser and sage
and black pepper shampoo I'm not gonna
lie the razors on my favorite product
I've had to choose one that wasn't a
razor it's got to be the body cleanser
cuz it smells so freakin good especially
when I use it on the money I shave
especially for my two dollars shave club
Vica guess how much that's worth 200
paddy this ad was weird but the deal is
not join the club with one of their
starters says for just $5 after that the
reefs top box ships regular sized
products at regular price just click the
link below the Dollar Shave Club a great
shave at a great price conveniently
delivered right to your home
you
[Applause]
so they at Tennessee to the group and
make their way to a nearby restaurant oh
my gosh you're the country Bears will
gave it away
I'm not takin I'm still working on it if
you're wondering why this waitress can't
act by the waves because it's Jennifer
Paige
far better at singing convincingly than
speaking convincingly oh my gosh really
country bears I'm sorry I didn't mean to
raise my voice like that you guys
inspired me to go after my dream become
a famous singer did you make it well I'm
in this movie so nope she gets a chance
to show off her singing chops and while
the musical segments in this aren't
awful they're pretty boring I feel like
the funny awkwardness of this movie
comes from how seriously the Bears are
taken but in musical numbers its kind of
expected you're supposed to act a little
silly so it's not quite as much fun no I
suppose it is a little humorous if
you've really analyzed it I always bring
my guitar to the kitchen this is when
the manager comes in like fired fired
fired fired fired fired animal hazards
but on the news they notice a very weird
newscaster this man was involved in the
abduction of this 10 year old boy in
this bus we'll keep you updated on us
watch I wish I could live my life with
the same excitement he uses to say bus
watch us watch actually that guy looks
familiar all of course he's the dude
with the viral dog he should really do
cartoons but the gravity falls can't
show up and chase them down the chase
itself isn't anything special but I am
loving more and more Hubble randomly put
bears in the background like they really
want to do some universe building where
bears get employment they need to pay
the bills they have lied to live the
more it seemed of the more I start
laughing it's just such a peculiar
detail
I'm in the carwash and again just the
weird acting from these two makes this
already odd scene even honor we're
watching a movie do you see we're
watching a moment we're watching to be
able to watch a movie we're watching a
movie one of them loses his fake
mustache which is never addressed as to
why he wore it and as a visual gag this
gets a bit of a chuckle out of me so he
does kind of look like I Medusa head
from Castlevania the bear stay at a
hotel and discover Tennessee's old
girlfriend is singing there so they go
to whoa button your shirt lady there's
children present I just want to show my
bare necessities now apparently just
Hartnell the voice of Wakko Warner is
supposed to be somewhere in this bar
listen if we can figure out where he is
this next song was written by an old
friend of mine in a band called the
country bears this movie's amazing even
this musical number which I just said
before I don't really get into in this
film it's freaking hilarious because
they play it so straight if somebody
told you this was a Spike Jonze music
video you'd call it genius
turn
I especially love this one woman who
just looks like she's in hell all the
other extras are trying to get into it
but she's just having none of this shit
every motion she has is like kill me
kill me kill me kill me kill me
fun fact by the way that's Bonnie Raitt
and Don Healy the actual singers of this
song being sung right now and they seem
to okay for their voices be coming out
of Yogi and Cindy bear except in this
universe there literally Eagles they go
to pick up the last member of the band
but accidentally get the wrong house
which country music cameo did you
blackmail this time Elton John that
country music icon can I help you yeah
an apology for Hakuna Matata that guy
John no judge taller I need to pick my
movies better I'm sure things will
improve when I go to Kingsman too they
go to a wedding where the final member
seems to be schmoozing with the rich but
they later find out he's just the
wedding singer nevertheless he still
doesn't want to play with them I'm not
goin your family that you go with that
was surprisingly gruesome they're so
happy go-lucky most of the time it's so
weird to see one of them give Bear punch
to the ground you can see there's the
crime photo in a newspaper the bears get
into an argument about why the band
broke up to begin with and Barry
I guess just now realizes he should go
back home resulting in this beautifully
awkwardly staged moment
[Music]
okay so I really have to give credit to
the animatronics and the puppeteering in
this it really is first-rate
it's amazing the range of expression and
movement these costumes emote it's very
well done but this is the one scene
where everybody looks completely lost
the people inside the puppeteers
operating the faces the cinematographer
nobody looks like they know what they're
supposed to be doing right now you can
practically hear the people inside the
suits talking film if you want
so Barry goes home kind about nowhere
but again emotional arcs aren't really
this film's focus
what is the film's focus is working on
even stranger questions like peri
listens to Nine Inch Nails
not only does this not match the music
he listens to not only does it not tie
into the kind of character he is though
God forbid that be really cool and
hilarious but now we have doing now it's
that Disney officially has Nine Inch
Nails in one of their properties and
it's the freaking country bears there is
no category for this kind of bonkers
despite Barry reconnecting with his
adoptive family and his new family
it looks like walk-in has kidnapped the
other bears and shown by this WTF edit
it was that simple fella oh my god I
have no idea what this movie is doing
but god help me it's making me laugh
walking puts them all in a cage with of
course a touch of his natural walking
move wait wait definitely changing back
home never died Chris never die as the
family tries to go and save them but
can't fit the bear into the car what the
hell were they gonna do when Barry got
older
this better not be used for a screwball
situation and or wacky climax ruin my
life walking finally reveals who he is
the kid who lost years ago in the talent
show any weird and rather weak twist but
let's be honest this was just an excuse
to get Chris for walking to do this to
write a whole movie to GIMP to do it
just like ask him what the definition of
car is and he'll just do that I love the
fact that there's five grown bears all
bigger than walking yet none of them
want to take him on because let's be
honest even an MMA fighter when one go
up against walking this crazy the rest
of the family of course shows up and can
you imagine being the team setting this
stunt up risking their lives so that
this crazy shit climax can be filmed
what if something went wrong what if uh
stuntmen died he would have taken his
last breath in a bear suit
filming the exciting conclusion of the
country bears movie that would be on his
tombstone some people should get Oscars
get on it they make it to country bear
Hall but it looks like no one showed up
because their agent made a deal with
walk in and didn't promote them and just
look at this face walking makes even for
him this is channeling a different
galaxy hey guy long time looking good
Amy you were gonna it's like he's
reliving a past life of an orangutan but
they find out Big Al advertised the show
himself and all the people were waiting
in the back this of course leads to the
line that brought a torn nation together
Oh every time he says that line a nest
of Pixies is born they of course played
to the crowd even let Barry rock his
guitar and everyone is super excited
except this guy he he's just not into it
[Music]
well I'm captain here oh yeah I'm okay
god damn it that's slightly cooler
[Applause]
I think that's the sound Haley Joel
Osment made when he found out what movie
he was recording for well at least
they're still better than maroon 5
and that was the country bears in all
honest to god seriousness I kind of had
a fun time with it this is what we do to
people who like in the country banners
is it I don't know no one's ever
admitted to liking it before wait
explain myself I guess but we're still
gonna shock your testicles occasionally
for good measure yeah that's fair
country bears it's not an especially
well-written movie and you could argue
does even less with the idea than the
already small amount that was presented
occasionally oh there's a joke that
works but for the most part it's
relatively David humor
where it does succeed is in how random
strange and unbalanced it is for most
films being unbalanced is a bad thing
but for this the tone is so inconsistent
that you have no idea they're gonna go
for a laugh or a serious moment and
whichever they choose it's always
hilariously bizarre it feels like
they're just trying anything any we're
performance any odd line and he freakin
kooky way of shooting a scene and that
surprisingly makes it a lot of fun to
watch I have oh no idea what the comedic
intent of this movie was maybe it was
all meant to be laughed at or maybe it
wasn't but I can say I smiled throughout
the whole thing because the humor isn't
in the intentional jokes in the
foreground but rather the unintentional
jokes in the background the extras the
crazy line reads the constant
questioning of how and why things are
happening if you go into this movie
constantly asking why to everything any
answer you come up with will be
hilarious it's like a Zen joke it just
asks you the right questions and you
fill in the answers to get the humor so
yeah i weirdly recommended i'm kind of
hoping it becomes one of those movies
that people look back on and say what
the hell were they thinking but kind of
in a loving way a way that appreciates
the energy this bought nandi the
strangeness and all-around fun
entirely sure what this movie was aiming
for but it entertained me and made me
laugh and for a freaking country Bears
movie to do that no matter what the
intent that is quite an accomplishment
[Music]
I guess it does make a little more sense
when he puts it like that my balls don't
thank you for your understanding yeah I
guess we can let this one go
are you insane next he'll be saying that
he likes the neverending story wait you
didn't like the neverending story oh
come on it's long and drawn-out and
boring and I'm gonna go this way now I'm
the Nostalgia Critic and there are some
stranger things than liking the country
Bears movie let me just figure out how
to get this a lot hey Doug Walker here
doing the charity shout out in this week
we are doing the Guide Dog Foundation
the Guide Dog Foundation welcomes people
who are blind or visually impaired to a
new friend and companion from their
compassionate and skilled instructors to
their exceptional dogs to their
meticulously constructed curriculum they
support their students with an
uncompromising commitment to excellence
this is a wonderful group with wonderful
animals that help wonderful people click
on the link and see how you can help
create a friendship that will never be
forgotten
[Music]